- Okay, very excited to be here today
to talk to you about work that
I've been doing as a postdoc
on the evolution of plant
shapes using these models
that we've been hearing
a lot about this morning.
So I think there was a good primer for the
work that I'm gonna present here
on many of the talks that we saw today.
I'm gonna focus on the
biological questions
and how those models can be applied
to a very specific biological question.
I wanna start by just showing
you this very basic pattern
of biodiversity, the distribution
of organisms on Earth
varies according to where you
are and what location you are.
This is a map showing the
number of vertebrate species.
So the hot colors are the locations
that contain many species.
And you can see that
it varies by latitude,
meaning the distance north
or south of the Equator.
So we see there are many
more species in the tropics
than there are contained in
the temperate environments
in North America and Asia.
One explanation for those differences
is that there are stark
climatic differences
between locations such that some locations
can afford the many
higher numbers of species
than are located in others, so this would
just be a comparison to say,
the Saharan Desert and
the tropics of Peru.
But there are also locations
where it seems to be
much more climatic similarity.
This looks like a very lush
forest in British Columbia,
but there's still many fewer species
contained in this forest
than there are in Peru.
This is a pattern that
we see across all taxa,
this is not just specific plants or birds,
it's across many varied groups of animals
and in particular, it is true that plants
generally follow a latitudinal
diversity gradient.
So here I'm just showing you the number
of flowering tree species on the X-axis.
And that number kinda binned according
to where you are in the
Earth and you can see
on this plot, that there
are many more species
contained in the equatorial latitudes
than there are outside of it.
But one component, so we
have known this pattern
for centuries essentially,
and biologists have
really been vexed by it
and we want to understand
why it exists and how it is related
to other aspects of biodiversity
that we're interested in.
So not all species are the same as saying
there are this many number of ecological
groupings in those locations.
So we wanna kind of tease
apart the number of species
from the number of ecologies.
One example of the way
that not all species
are ecologically unique
is an example from birds.
The Zosterops genus of birds
is a group of white-eyes.
So this is the white-eye
here down this image
and the image that I'm showing you
over there, is six different
species of white-eyes.
And so to the lay observer,
it might just look
all like the same bird, right?
So, what's true is that,
just because there are
six different species,
really we could call these
kind of the same ecology.
There are six species, but
maybe one ecological function.
And so we wanna tease apart
these aspects of say, shape
from the other taxonomic diversity
that we described in
museums for centuries.
So we know that species that are similar
in shape and size perform a
similar ecological function.
Which raises two questions.
The first is how does shape diversity
vary according to latitude?
We know that the number of species
changes according to latitude.
And that informs another and
deeper fundamental question
about evolution biology which is,
whether species at different latitudes
have some sort of different
ability to carve up
the ecological space in those places.
So is it that tropical
species are really just able
to become more finely
and specifically adapted
towards one ecological
function, and that's the reason
why we've jammed so many more species
in those locations than otherwise?
So plant leaf shapes are obviously
very diverse and complex.
We've certainly all
walked around in a forest
and looked around and seen many
different shapes and sizes.
There's just a schematic
there of some of the different
shapes of leaves as they're,
in particular species,
as they develop, so there's
obviously also changes
according to development.
But there's also this very basic pattern
that's known in plant shape
according to latitude,
which is that high latitude temperate
locations have more toothed leaves.
So the edges of this
leaf are called toothed
and this tropical leaf has
what's called an entire margin
and so the absence of tooths
in tropical locations.
So evolutionary biologists
have been trying
to study this difference
and we're kind of interested
in a next level of complexity.
One that doesn't necessarily
involve just saying
this is toothed, this is not,
but something more complex.
So we've heard a lot this
morning about the magic
of computer vision and
how it might help us
and reduce some of this complexity
to understand shape differences.
So we focus our study
on ferns of the world.
There are about 12,000 species
of ferns distributed globally.
Here are two such examples.
Two specimens that are contained
in the US National Herbarium
and they're two different species.
I think it's fairly obvious
that they look very different
and that difference is very complex.
So it might be difficult to measure
the difference between those two organisms
except for if we might use something like
a convolutional neural net
to extract that information.
The distribution of ferns of the world
follows these kind of similar pattern
to what we find among other organisms.
There are many more species
contained in the tropics.
This is actually just a quick estimate
of the number of species
that might be located
in different places on
Earth, using a dataset
that we heard about
this morning called GBIF
or the Global Biodiversity
Information Facility.
So I took all of the occurrences
that existed on GBIF for
ferns and mapped them
according to where they were found.
These are for all occurrences that had
some decimal lat and long.
We find that again, there
are many more species
contained in the tropics.
Ferns are also highly diverse
in both size and shape.
So, here are eight specimens
of eight different species.
You can see that there's
really a lot of complexity here
that we'd like to understand,
but it's not so obvious
how we might get to that answer
if not for some large scale method
that would help us put
all these eight species
in some sort of high dimensional,
or low dimensional space
based on their differences which are
clearly very high dimensional.
So ferns have been completely digitized
at the US National Herbarium.
We heard about the digitization
effort this morning.
I just wanna show you, this
is kind of what an herbarium
looks like, it looks almost
nothing like that normally.
That is just when you wanna
get a really cool image
for everyone to look at,
normally it's just a bunch
of file cabinets that are closed.
But there are flat specimens
that we can then digitize
which is a really useful way in which
we've kind of moved
forward with this project.
So our approach was to
take all of the specimens
that are contained, all
the digitized specimens
that we could find for ferns,
not only in the Smithsonian,
but also on a larger, kind of
international collaboration,
mostly focused on North America called
The Integrated Digitized
Biocollections or iDigBio.
So we took images from iDigBio as well
as images from Smithsonian
to train three models.
The first model was to
identify, or label the specimen
according to the genus of the plant,
of the fern on the image.
And we only, we built kind of
this as our simplest model,
which is that we took genera that had
at least 500 occurrences in our dataset.
So we've kind of eluded to it all day,
but it's more difficult to learn features
when you have fewer training examples.
In this case, we wanted there to be
at least 500 training
examples for each genus.
But we started to change
that up as we found
that our original model
we incredibly accurate,
so we wanted to kinda
test the limits of it.
We made a model where there
were 50 specimens per genus.
So a lot of this is
related to where botanists
have collected plants around the world
and how those collections have been built.
So there's somewhat of
that biased in terms of,
you know, where the
specimens are distributed
and which specimens we found.
But partly, rare specimens
tend to come from places
that botanists don't visit very often
and might be unique, so
that's kind of why we
kind of moved around like this.
So we built a genera model with 269 genera
for about 50 specimens and then,
ultimately, a 1,425 species model
with at least 50 specimens per species.
So in each case, the
model gets more complex
and it will be more
challenging for our model
to distinguish between
the different labels
that we're going to give it.
So we talked a little bit this morning
about confusion matrices,
but this is essentially
how we validate the model
after we've trained it.
In the first case we had
hundreds of thousands of images
and we carved up our training set into 80%
of those images that we
would train our data with,
and 20% of those images,
which it had never seen,
we're now going to ask
how good is it at giving
the correct label that
we actually already know.
So for a given genus, the actual genus A,
we have some proportion of the labels
that the neural net then
generates for that genus.
And we can plot those
accordingly in that A row.
What you wanna see is that blue diagonal
where it would be 100% of the actual genus
was predicted to be A at the bottom.
But sometimes there is some confusion.
It's true that the model
is certainly not perfect.
And oftentimes, that confusion happens
between things that are closely related.
So in this case, we're
looking at three genus
from a family of what's
called, the tree ferns.
And there tended to be more confusion say,
within this family than outside of it.
But the model was
incredibly accurate overall.
At 97% accuracy to identify the
genus in our 86 genus model.
And that accuracy didn't change too much
when we moved to the 269 genus model.
And you can see that
it was highly accurate
across that diagonal, but it's those boxes
that contain families of genera,
where you see more confusion.
So that's telling us that
the model is operating
according to the biologist's intuition.
It's not accidentally making mistakes,
too widely outside of the
exact type of mistakes
that a less-trained botanist might make
if they were making
identifications in the field,
or if they weren't using a hand lens.
Many of these genera are
distinguished by traits
that are essentially not
visible by the human eye.
So it's pretty incredible in that way,
that the machine is
actually learning patterns
of differences that we don't currently use
to differentiate between them.
So when we trained our model on species,
it remained a highly accurate model
and some of the inaccuracies
were, I think, forgivable.
First off, I just am
showing you two plots.
These are kind of basic
metrics that you gather
as you train a neural
network, and we talked
a little bit this morning about EPICs,
which are individual
periods where you cycle
your entire training
dataset through the model.
And so the model is constantly changing.
What we're doing is
essentially feeding images
through this model, it has
some prediction at the end
and there's an error with that prediction
and we want to modify the parameters
in a way that would reduce that error.
So that error is the loss that your seeing
here on the Y-axis on this panel.
We want that loss to be plummeting
as we're training the model.
And there's a loss both based
on the training dataset,
and on the validation training set,
or on the validation set, and
usually what you end up with
is that the training set has a lower loss
because it's starting to
converge on specific things
that it's learning about those images.
So as soon as that starts to
plateau, you stop training.
But we also have accuracy, the accuracy is
both the exact match accuracy,
but also the accuracy in the top five.
So in this case, I'm showing
the exact match accuracy,
which is about 81.5% for species.
But for the top five predictions,
it gets the right species
in that top five at 95.6% of the time.
And that is pretty incredible.
Essentially, a lot of species
are just differentiated
by genetic markers, so the
actual shape differences
that the images are going
to be able pick up on
are almost nonexistent, and so,
for the model to get
that level of accuracy
I think is a forgivable level of error.
So what is this FernNet using
to make it's identifications?
Here I'm showing you four example images
that were passed through the network.
And then four activation
maps, essentially,
these are the pixels that the neural net
found most interesting and most relevant
to making a prediction.
And the good thing is, is that the heat
or the hot colors in these heat maps
are over top of the plant,
and not on the label.
(laughing)
It's not learning how to read the label,
it's learning something about the images.
We can also make some really
cool things called feature maps.
Essentially, what I'm gonna show you next
is the different output of specific layers
in our neural network and essentially,
what we would be looking at is
what the filter might look like that would
activate for that layer of the model.
Earlier layers in these
image recognition models
tend to look more like shapes and patterns
and high level layers
tend to be very specific
for making those final distinctions
between say, species A or species B.
So here are four example feature maps.
There are hundreds of
layers in this model,
so I can't show you all
of the feature maps,
but how they've built these
is by randomly populating
an image with colors, and
then optimizing that image
so that it would maximally
activate that layer.
So yes, they look
technicolored and more like
the 90s color palette of neon,
but the colors don't matter very much.
And that's, I think, a
really important part about
our model, is that it's
not activating by color,
the colors tend to be very invariant.
The shapes are highly variable
and it's really more about shape.
So you can see that later
filter, maybe if you squint
your eyes, it looks a little
bit like a complex fern frond.
So it's kind of getting
towards our fern shapes.
Okay, we saw a little bit about why or how
these models work to generate
from a very complex data input,
a very low dimensional or single,
ah, two dimensional vector
at the very end, and that vector,
the 1 x 496 vector, right before
it gets to 1 x 1425 vector,
which is actually the
probability that our image
is within the 1425 different levels,
that 496 vector is the
one that we wanna project
in our UMAP space like
we saw earlier today
with the PixPlot projections.
In this case, we're using a model
that was specifically
trained to understand
the differences of
specie shapes for ferns.
So we're not using the larger,
kind of front-end model
from ImageNet or ResNet
or something like that
that's pre-trained, we're
using a model that's trained
on these things so we think
those feature embeddings
at 496 vector is actually
a really, a useful vector
not for trying to understand the variation
in say, the label or this color ramp,
because every one of
these images has that.
So the model should have basically
stopped learning about those.
So we take those and we project them
into a two dimensional space
and we can get our shape space for ferns.
So in this case, what we're looking at
is a two dimensional
projection of each point
is representative of one of those images.
Just like we saw earlier
today with the cool
visualizations that PixPlot generated.
We could look at this
image and kind of drill in
and look at each individual specimen
and where it's positioned
within this shape space.
So here I've just thrown
up two example images
and we see that they look quite different
from one another, there is
actually a Euclidean distance
that is preserved in this projection,
so we can measure the
distance between them
as some aspect of their shape
dissimilarity or similarity.
And we can then use that to understand
this latitudinal diversity gradient.
So, here I'm actually now
just dividing the world,
instead of looking at latitudinal
differences continuously,
I've just divided the world
into four unique groupings.
Tropical climates,
mountain desert climates,
temperate climates for the blue ones,
and the dark blue is the polar climates.
And now I'm just gonna
label our shape space
based on whether or not our ferns
fell into these categories.
And lo and behold, there's
definitely some clustering
related to where those ferns are evolving,
where they're operating ecologically
and where they are in
our shape dimensions.
You can see that there's kind of a cluster
of temperate things, it
kinda surrounds this,
maybe other cluster of tropical
things, which is very cool,
and then there's this all this scatter
and a lot of that scatter
is tropical plants.
And so that tells us that
not only is this operating
this species' richness,
this number of species
in a given location is
operating on the creating
more genetic diversity,
but it also potentially,
is creating or associated with more
shape diversity or ecological diversity.
So how does morphological shape
states evolve according to latitude?
Or vary according to latitude?
I think this is kind of the first step
at really accessing this,
one of these projections,
we could kind of create a
way to redo this process
and look more deeply at it statistically,
but essentially, there are
some kind of unique variations.
And the next step is
to kind of combine that
with our analysis of the species' numbers.
And so that's what we're working on now.
So with that, many contributors to this.
We've heard about this
botany digitization project,
I think a number of times.
Huge thanks to the efforts
that are not only going
into digitizing the botany collection,
that's happening at Peabody and many other
Natural History museums around the world,
but the efforts to
digitize these collections
are really the only
way that we can perform
analysis of this scale,
so thanks very much.
(audience applauding)
(gentle music)